the FBI probe into Brett Kavanaugh could
be finished in a matter of hours the
bureau expected to wrap things up as
early as today sources telling Fox News
a single copy of the report will be sent
to Capitol Hill and the White House to
read and then it's going to be kept in a
safe in the Senate Judiciary Committee
this all comes as Senator Chuck Grassley
is demanding answers to stunning new
allegations that contradict Christine
Blasi Ford's testimony an ex-boyfriend
claims Ford helped a friend prep for a
polygraph test contradicting her at
Senate testimony have you ever had
discussions with anyone besides your
attorneys on how to take a polygraph
never and I don't just mean
countermeasures but I mean just any sort
of tips or anything like that
no have you ever given tips or advice to
somebody who is looking to take a
polygraph test
never now Ford's friend is denying being
helped for a lie-detector test meantime
President Trump isn't backing down from
defending Cavanaugh from democratic
attacks he's swinging back harder than
ever they've been trying to destroy
judge Kavanaugh since the very first
second he was announced so many
different charges guilty until proven
innocent that's very dangerous for our
country and a man's life is in tatters a
man's life is shattered they destroy
people they want to destroy people these
are really evil people and after the
bombshell story about Cavanaugh throwing
ice cubes at a bar the New York Times is
out with another decades-old report
about the Supreme Court nominee The
Times printing what appears to be a
sarcastic letter from Kavanaugh
preparing for Beach week in the summer
of 1983 where he warns about him and his
friends being loud and getting drunk all
right Greg this I guess this is a sworn
statement by the ex-boyfriend of Ford
and it's riddled with bombshells here
never brought
anything about Kavanagh never his name
never brought up about being sexually
abused he witnessed her prepping this
friend of hers Monica for a polygraph
exam she flew in planes all the time not
afraid of small spaces end when he
caught her cheating he she ended up
keeping his credit card and then
spending lavishly on it then lied about
it afterwards and then once it was said
that he was going to press charges then
she owned up to it now that you know
what's the key thing to take from this
is that two can play at this game in the
court of public opinion okay we've sat
here and watched uncorroborated
accusation so it's now the pendulum is
swinging back and there happens to be
information out there that the media is
saying that Trump's comments about Ford
were mockery or an attack are the same
media who thought Matt Damon's ridicule
of Cavanaugh was sparkling and brilliant
and daring and yet they find that Trump
said something yesterday and they called
it mockery or an attack when all he did
was point out a discrepancy what Trump
did if that was an attack to you then
you really do live in a bubble because
if you go home or you go to a bar or you
talk to somebody at the gym what Trump
said is exactly the opinions of
everybody at home going some of her
stuff has holes in it that stuff about
having one drink but not knowing she
only had one drink but not remembering
everything else the common sense of his
of the of the what would you call they
rally Trump the common sense of the
rally Trump reflects most of America and
he's revealing the contrast of the
public and private expression about this
case that so many people publicly will
say she's credible and compelling but
then they go home and they go dude she's
not making sense on a lot of it so he's
remember he said at the beginning
compelling but then when he gets to
rally Trump he becomes like everybody
else and he says you know what she's
when you come to rally Trump what he
does is he feeds red meat to the red
base no that's me and your America and
you were going to go after the press the
media's doing it let me just tell you
Greg pick up the
paper you'll see that people like Susan
Collins are saying this is plain wrong
that's your chair people of the media
let me finish for a second oh no you
interrupted me it did not I respond to
you I'm saying and you hear Lindsey
Graham say well there may be some holes
but you know what mr. president knock it
off this Iran helpful they're probably
tell you something great this kind of
going after someone when they give you a
bearing nurses oh yeah it's something
that has trauma telecafe ah it's not
helpful that women get a message from
this that they are being towed up women
actually agreed with Trump at that rally
oh yeah they no they applauded how about
yes so how about when the Catholic
Church abuses people in the power
structure ignores them and protects the
priests what about the they go to the
elevator of Jeff Flake and if you
support Brett Kavanaugh you're not
listening to me well you know what if
you were molested and we now know
they're soros funded people if you were
Melissa go after the guy who molested
you don't assume that Brett Kavanaugh
should carry the burden for everyone who
has suffered every woman from sexual
events what we're talking about judge
even Jeff Blake said what Trump did last
night no time no place for remarks like
that because it is insulting and the
lawyer for Lord said this is why women
don't comfort that's why you don't tell
your dad don't tell your mom you feel
robbed a simple discrepancy Sarah
Sanders was asked about this today at
the briefing let's hear what she had to
say it wasn't anything other than the
president stating facts in fact facts
that were laid out in the prosecutors
memo that she put forward to the Senate
I think it is absolutely disgraceful
what they've done and exploited this
process they exploited dr. Ford they're
exploiting all of the women that have
come out to make any type of accusation
this isn't the process that should have
been done and certainly everybody
deserves to be heard but that includes
Judge Cavanaugh well I just got a fresh
text from mom and I'm gonna have to go
to you if she mom says I sincerely hope
that Dana establishes the tone tonight
regarding attack
the victim so here we go Dana well the
thing is I was it was interesting I
think Sarah Sanders she represents her
boss well white she's she's been in
position nobody talks like Trump
nobody can out Trump Trump so you're the
press secretary and you she's I think
she did her best there and trying to say
this is what he was trying to say what
President Trump was saying was basically
reading from the transcript of the
hearing but it's a tone thank your mom
says me from me to set the town yeah so
the president has a tone that does sound
like he is going after you that's like
for me like you know I hate the
nicknames like I get it that they work
and that they're very effective I do
though wonder about the strategy later
on because flake Murkowski Collins their
sincerely polite they would never say
this kind of thing and so now they're
already under a ton of pressure they're
waiting for this FBI report the
president needs their votes and I just
think like from a strategy standpoint do
you do you get the country with you and
lose those three votes and then end up
winning in 2020 because people are so
mad or do those people those senators
wait for the FBI report if it's clean if
they would have no reason not to vote
for him if the FBI report comes back and
it's fine but but I really believe Dana
that that Donald Trump always has both
situations covered he's got the public
situation covered and the political and
that's why he plays to his base and then
he also is trying to leverage however
way he can with these senators play in
this well I think said maybe I think
that even if he loses a flake right all
right does he pick up a mansion does he
pick up somebody else along the way
McCaskill somebody like I don't think
anybody said no I don't think what we
saw at the rally last night that was not
mocking Trump and I've also seen Trump
mocking who can play at this game right
see the media put their spotlights on a
vanetti and questionable client all
right and let it ride and and so then
then you have Trump just bring up a
simple discrepancy and you call that
like attacking give me a break
I'll give you a break that was a tack
I'll tell you something where it's no
place okay so in other words every woman
in America who's gone not every woman
was saw oh they're all snowflakes why
don't you just shut up you know move on
no nothing to see here this I don't know
what it is this to me is also part of
the issue with the FBI
because right now remember the president
said he found Ford credible that's the
president slang that's polite and then
he comes now and instead now he changes
his tune because he wants to play to you
Gregg and your ilk who has been a victim
of a sexual assault remembers more than
Christine blazing I know I did this for
30 years every woman know know what I'm
telling you is that for you to say that
because Donald Trump is pointing out
inconsistencies in her own testimony
that he's suggesting to other women
who've been victimized that hey look
we're not gonna believe you it's
absolutely not the case
oh the women who've been victimized or
risk in the same questions why do I
remember when I was ringing why do I
remember here's what I spoke with most
women who were victimized don't even
report it because fear is not the
president of the United States and the
politics what they fear is the invasion
in which you don't interview the victim